United Airlines is really really pushing
Dei all the airlines are all the
companies are but United in particular
the CEO Scott Kirby has announced that
he's going to stop caring so much about
whether his Pilots can actually fly
planes and he's going to care a lot more
about whether they're you know black
pygmy lesbians so right uh so is
it can can of be a pygmy or vice
for I don't know I'll think about this
later uh you you might recall I think we
played the clip on the show last week or
the week before this guy has a radical
leftwing vision for his airline how is
diversity and diversity targets working
into the avate academy we have committed
that 50% of the class of of the classes
will be women or people of color uh
today only 19% of our Pilots at United
Airlines are women or people of color
and by the way from all the data I've
seen that's the highest of any airline
in the country white males don't just
dominate in the cockpits also in the sea
suite at United airl lines well look at
United I'm proud of the diversity that
we actually have in our our SE Suite I
think if you look around Corporate
America correct me if I'm saying though
so I this was just based off your
website the people you list as
Executives but out of 11 people three
are women I believe one is a person of
color um that's correct um but you know
in Corporate America I think you know
that's a low bar how do you raise your
own bar well a lot of this is you know
focusing on it we have uh programs to
one of the things we do is for every job
when we do an interview we require women
and people of color to be involved in in
the interview process bringing people in
early in their careers um as well uh and
giving them those opportunities and
creating a stronger bench okay that's it
I also mentioned last week Dei in your
restaurant means you care about
diversity more than your dinner Dei in
your school means you care about
diversity more than your education Dei
in the cockpit means you care about
diversity more than your life
I could not possibly care less if United
Airlines ever hires a single
additional black lesbian gender Studies
major to fly an airplane I'm skeptical
that uh diversity quotas will help
anyone fly the only thing I care about
in the cockpit is whether people are
good at flying airplanes and won't kill
me and 200 other people that's all I
care about don't care about how they
look don't care about even what they
think about a lot of can you fly an
airplane all right why on Earth would
United Airlines Chief among all of the
airlines be pushing this kind of leftist
craziness well our friends over at Libs
of Tik Tok have suggested one
explanation which is it turns out this
guy is reportedly a drag queen and there
are these videos of him doing weird drag
shows and all sorts of other pictures of
him doing drag shows that I uh won't
post uh I hesitated even to cover this
story because I don't have any desire to
personally humiliate anybody
now this guy obviously allowed himself
to be videotaped he's doing this sort of
stuff publicly so I don't feel that I'm
uncovering any private sins exactly but
it it is humiliating the whole thing is
humil the minute he put on the stilettos
that's a humiliating act and I guess the
guys the guy into crossdressing or
whatever
okay do you think that might have
anything to do with his Embrace of
radical leftist
politics I think it does I think the
lesson here for conservatives is
personal vices create political problems
you can't neatly compartmentalize these
two things a lot of people lowercase L
liberals classical liberals Libertarians
they they want to compartmentalize life
so you say well what I do in private is
nobody's business it has nothing to do
with anybody and I can totally neatly
separate my personal views and behavior
from my public and political views and
but you can't you're a person you're a
per you're not two people people even
though today people use the plural
pronoun to refer to themselves they say
you know I am they and they are me and I
Am The Walrus goj but you're not really
two
people some some others say my my name
is Legion for we are many you're not
really many you might have other
spiritual problems going on but you're a
person and
so to to give credit actually to the
feminists of the
1970s when they said the personal is the
political they were right actually the
proof that they were right is that they
totally remade politics they were
completely politically Successful by
obliterating that distinction between
the personal and the private we all want
to have some reasonable privacy we we
don't want the public to intrude on our
private lives and our families and and
everything of
course but that position becomes less
and less tenable the weirder you are
personally the more depraved you become
personally the more vices that you acrew
the the the the the more bizarre your
family situation becomes the the more
the less able you are to have a private
life because that is going to so clearly
encroach on the public sector I mean the
the moment that you say you family isn't
real and I'm going to live in a in a
thruple polycule with three dudes in a
billy goat and you're going to call us
all husbands and wives and we're going
to adopt children and we're going all of
a sudden now you're in you're in the
you've very quickly left the bedroom you
in the realm of major public and
political questions and if we have a
country of a bunch of cross-dressing
porn addled weirdos then you're not
going to have a virtuous polity you're
not going to neatly separate the the
private life from the political life the
the more you act like a radical leftist
in your private life the more radically
leftist the politics of the country are
going to become because a country is
made up of people that's what politics
is about it's about
people a lot of technocrats and extreme
ideolog they want to pretend that people
don't matter people are just statistics
people are just automatons they're just
the masses to be led on no no we've got
the ideology we wrote it and five bullet
points on the back of a napkin we don't
we don't need to care about no it's
people man that's it that's what it
comes down to no but we have the
Constitution
Constitution without people who can
actually put it into
effect and a buck 50 will get you a cup
of coffee under Trump under Biden it
takes like 450 because of inflation con
a constitution letters on piece of paper
doesn't mean anything without people to
actually put it into effect laws courts
of Justice it means nothing without
people who have self-control and a deep
enough education intellectual and
habitual to actually live that
out a nation
of of sex freaks is not going to be a
virtuous Nation okay that's that's where
we have to start talking about the
bedroom okay I don't want to talk about
anyone's bedroom but it's bleeding out
into the the streets and it's weird and
it's making our country worse after
we've been told for years that Ukraine
is the Vanguard of democracy Vladimir
zalinski is the Winston Churchill of our
times he probably makes a lot of quotes
from Budweiser advertisements too he
this is the man you know he's mobilized
the Ukrainian language and sent it into
war he is the great defender of
Freedom well there's a story that
basically no one is talking about which
is that an American Journal
was imprisoned and killed in a Ukrainian
prison simply for voicing his opinion
that journalist is Gonzalo lra I'm
totally unfamiliar with his work I've
never watched a video of his I I take it
that he's popular on YouTube and in some
of the the manosphere and the red pill
circles bit eccentric and he was over in
Ukraine and he was arrested for voicing
his opinion on that war
and not sufficiently supporting the
zalinsky regime and so they arrested him
they imprisoned him his health started
to fail the ukrainians didn't lift a
finger it seems to help him the US state
department didn't lift a finger it seems
to help him and then he died how are
more people not talking about
this all we ever hear about especially
from the leftwing press in America is
how those journalists they're the fourth
estate the Intrepid Defenders of
democracy we need to stop all those
autocratic regimes from silencing the
Press killing the press in this case oh
unless it's sininsky unless it's our
guys doing it unless it's the liberal
preferred
autocrats then they can they can kill
journalists they can kill American
citizens they kill American journalists
doesn't matter as long as it's them it's
not that evil Putin when was the last
time Putin killed an American journalist
when was the last time Xian ping killed
an American
journalist
huh I I think I think what what have we
given Ukraine so far $2 billion no more
than that much more than that I'm sorry
we're missing 1.7 billion in military
equipment I think that's
enough I I think we've given enough and
I think even if it makes zalinsky a
little uneasy I think that the plan to
wind down the war in Ukraine advocated
by the presumptive Republican nominee
for president just fine by me man that
was a great clip wasn't it now make sure
that you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel and we'll see
you next time